all right this is a candy crush soda
saga
level 13 walkthrough tutorial
i'm adding some commentary here so you
can see how to use the tips in our guide
this level's changed several times since
it was first released but
this seems to be the final um
version for now everyone has it there
was actually a period of time when there
was two versions
and different players had different ones
the mobile app hasn't been updated this
week yet though so it has 26 moves
and facebook has 30. so you might see
that change happen
just to note the first video that you'll
find in our guide
shows it being completed when it only
had 25 moves so it can be done
you usually want to make that match
right away
that's a combo that's changed um
from the original framing crush
and i think that's why this level starts
out with that there this is kind of show
you
sort of showcase the um
the change
when you now
i'm not going to go through all the
different combos and what they do
because we have detailed guides about
that but i will say you should go check
it out because um
the combos are a little bit different
than what you you're used to if you're
been playing candy crush for a long time
and you will need
a big combo to beat this level this is
the type of level that you're never
going to be able to get all this icing
blockers out of the way just by making
matches
so once you get some space cut kind of
cleared out like i did
now you're trying to set up
combos while working your way down and
conserving moves
it's kind of
it can be kind of tough to figure that
out because you know you don't want to
you don't want to waste too many moves
kind of like what i'm doing
here to make a color bomb
but at the same time you need
coloring bombs
or color bombs or coloring candies in
order to get done so
you just sort of have to um
use your judgment and sometimes you know
you won't finish but
if you do what i do in this video then
you will eventually get past it when
that situation is
good
all right so like i mentioned we need to
make big big combos
and
those are going to be like
fish but your color color bombs really
good
color bomb plus a color bomb is really
good
pretty much on this level any of them
but any any special candy plus a color
bomb is going to be pretty good
coloring candy is is the same i mean
there's really you really can't go wrong
making a big um
combo with a color bomber coloring candy
on this level
so that's what i'm trying to do
and you know a lot of times that's going
to be easier said than done but like i
said
you know with a level like this you just
sort of have to plug along and see
when the opportunities come up
all right so finally we got that
taken care of and
this is a brand new combo obviously
since fish are brand new
but you can see just how
effective it can be so even though i had
to kind of waste a lot of moves to get
to that
in the end i would say it was worth it
we're not all the way out of the woods
yet because we only have four moves left
and
we've got one two
we still have blockers here and we have
quite a few pieces of ice
this is a little bit counterintuitive
but
i think this is our best bet here we
have to remove these five pieces that
are covering the bear
so what i'm gonna do is
go ahead and activate the fish
we're going to make this striped which
will sit next to our
and um
let's see what happens i mean it's not
guaranteed but i think we have a pretty
good chance here
there we go